WE WANT TO KNOW THAT YOU WILL,
THE BEST.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WASHINGTON IS PANICKING OVER THE
PRESIDENT'S LATEST EFFORTS TO
CREATE A RATIONAL FOREIGN POLICY
WITH UKRAINE IMPEACHMENT EFFORT
TRUDGES FORWARD.
YOU'VE HEARD ENDLESSLY ON CABLE
NEWS IT'S UNPRECEDENTED THAT THE
PRESIDENT WOULD SEEK POLITICAL
GAIN FROM A CONVERSATION WITH A
FOREIGN LEADER.
IT TURNS OUT IT'S HAPPENED
BEFORE.
BACK IN 2000, WE CAN REPORT,
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH TONY BLAIR OF
THE U.K. AND ASKED HIM DIRECTLY
TO INTERCEDE IN A DISPUTE
BETWEEN BRITISH AIRWAYS AND
AMERICAN CARRIERS.
THE PRESIDENT AT THE TIME WAS
MUCH MORE DIRECT AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS IN HIS
CONVERSATION WITH THE UKRAINIAN
LEADER.
THIS IS BILL CLINTON BACK THEN.
I'M QUOTING.
"IN A POLITICAL SEASON, IT WOULD
BE BIG OVER HERE TO GET THIS
OPEN SORE RESOLVED.
IF YOU COULD HAVE SOMEBODY TAKE
A LOOK AT IT, HE ASKED."
TONY BLAIR RESPONDED THAT HE
WOULD.
IS THIS A BIG DEAL?
NOT REALLY.
IS IT NAKEDLY POLITICAL?
IS IN AN EFFORT TO USE A FOREIGN
COUNTRY TO INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME
OF AN ELECTION IN A PRESIDENTIAL
YEAR?
YES, IT IS, OBVIOUSLY.
INCIDENTALLY, IT DID NOT TAKE US
LONG TO FIND THE TRANSCRIPT FROM
WILL INTERDICT HER OLD CLINTON
TRANSCRIPTS FOR ABOUT
15 MINUTES.
THEY ARE ALL CAPS, THEY ARE ALL
IN LINE.
PROBABLY A LOT MORE EXAMPLES AND
IF WE FIND THAT WE WILL BRING
THEM TO YOU BUT THE POINT IS
ANYONE COMMENTING ON THIS,
ANYONE STARING AT THE SCREEN,
AND THERE ARE COUNTLESS PEOPLE
WHO FIT THE DESCRIPTION AND
TELLING YOU THIS IS NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE, IT'S OUTRAGEOU
OUTRAGEOUS.
NONE OF THEM TOOK THE TIME TO